thank you please what I went out but I
know what a thank you very much I think
I think we're all speaking the same
thing
TGIF after a week of WTF seems like
there was like a year's worth of news
that was stuffed into butt so let's just
start at the beginning okay the
president fired the FBI director the man
who was investigating him how'd you like
to be able to do that a cop pulls you
over you're under arrest sir oh yeah
you're fired
think about that
and the way he did it of course Trump
can't do anything without doing it like
a little [ __ ] 1min enjoyed the show
I've lost my mind already as a pace
yourself billet but true I instead of
calling Comey up like a real man would
do and telling him or in person no he
sends his albino assassin with a letter
that says you are hereby terminated
removed from office effective
immediately
sincerely Vladimir Putin so that was
that was on Tuesday all the next day
Trump has his surrogates go out there
and say well this was all very routine
the president simply lost confidence in
director company's ability to mislead
and it came down to a character issue
yeah call me handsome
[Applause]
[Music]
yes did you get the main reason they
said that called me had to go at nothing
to do with Russia it was all about how
unfair he was to Hillary this insulted
Sarah Palin's intelligence cuz you know
if there's one thing Trump will not
abide its bad-mouthing his dear friend
crooked Hillary do not lock her up do
not remember they were chanting that do
not lock her up yes I remember so so
Trump has his people tell this story
about Hillary and about how the fee was
just accepting the recommendation of the
Attorney General and then yesterday he
goes on Lester Holt show and just nope
it was me no it was all my idea I know
only was it all my idea but I did it for
the reason you think to stop the
investigation he said this he said it
out loud he said when I decided to fire
call me quote I said to myself this
Russia thing with Trump himself in the
third birthday
this Russia thing with Trump and Russia
is a made-up story Putin must be in the
Kremlin going oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
time to deactivate his microchip he
admitted obstruction of justice right
there on live national television and
the Republicans nothing to see here
because we all now live in America raagh
wha would you like a little banana with
your Republic can you imagine what the
Republicans would be saying if Hillary
was doing this the articles of
impeachment would not just be drafted
Roger stone would have them tattooed on
his back - and you know a little over a
hundred days we are in this
administration the attorney acting
Attorney General Fayed national security
adviser you're fired
FBI director you're welcome to
apprentice nuclear addition
is it any wonder that people are
comparing this to Nixon and the Saturday
night massacre and by the way I love
this the people at the Nixon
Presidential Library objected to this as
they should what did it say when
supporters of the guy who was so tainted
by scandal that he had to resign are
like don't bring our guy into that and I
haven't even gotten to the part where
the day after he fires call me he has
the Russian Foreign Minister and the
Russian ambassador into the Oval Office
which is never done because they're
[ __ ] spies so they're never in the
Oval Office and he would not allow
American media in there just the Russian
photographer so to recap for you
Trump fires the chief investigator into
Russia then he invites the Russians into
his oval office the next morning kicks
out the American media but has the
Russian state-run press there and
confesses to obstruction of justice on
live TV but Hillary sent some emails
from the wrong laptop
yeah yeah you Bernie or bust people
Hillary wasn't pure enough look what you
have now call me for a lot of the
Liberals wasn't pure enough who do you
think you're going to get for an FBI
director now I'm going to go out on a
limb and say it's probably not going to
be a black guy or a woman the
administration says they're looking for
somebody fair-minded independent and
Trump's son-in-law